justement demandé que le prix
jamel debbouze qui se replonge quelques
instants dans le bain de l'improvisation
un cadeau destiné aux collégiens qui
participait vendredi dernier à paris à
la finale nationale du trophée culture
et diversité
une courte séquence qu'il y marquer
aussi les retrouvailles dans la
patinoire avec alain degois papy le
fondateur de déclic théâtre celui qui
l'a lancé attrape au collège cours vers
c'était en 1990 et 2000
airbus est perdue les jambes ville la
veille venus de lille rochefort bordeaux
et rap c'est ici que les jeunes se
préparent à monter sur la scène mais
surtout échangent discutent et tissent
des liens ils sont pas encore dans le
dans le dans l'objectif qui peut être
celui de la gagne de demain et ils sont
contents d'être là de partager ils vont
être voilà c'est
ouais sont très positifs en tout cas et
puis puis vont très vite les uns vers
les autres en fait il se trouve des
affinités
on va apprendre à se connaître ce soir
on va dire et on va parler on va danser
one à la musique
je pense qu'on va faire ça soit à 22
heures quand même pas dormir on va dire
qu'il sera pas fatigué quand après avoir
mangé donc moi personnellement je sais
que j'ai pas dormi de la nuit que je
sais que mes copines et tout donc
bataille d'oreillers je sais pas trop
quoi mais c'est sûr que je vais pas
dormir en tout cas l'improvisation
prétexte à rapprocher des jeunes de
différents milieux même si cela reste
une compétition on s'observe déjà on
estime ses chances de l'emporter à
trappes
on est on a tous un style différent et
ceux ci deux réunis ça donne ainsi de
choc et c'est ce qui fait c'est ce qui
fait notre personnalité on est inique et
quant à elle sur la patinoire bas ça on
se défoule tout ce qu'on nous parle le
sort pour jouer et aussi en attendant ça
à dire des clichés sur trappe comme quoi
c'est une
c'est une banlieue on sait pas faire de
l'impro on se dit que déjà échoué mais
moi je trouve pas je pensais
d'originalité et va
champion en titre dans ce tournoi c'est
donc une équipe en toute confiance
qu'ils se présentent vendredi à paris
seulement ces dernières années le niveau
à progresser la fièvre de l'impro à
gagner le reste de la france et ses
vertus se sont aussi diffusés marc
ladreit de lacharrière qui a créé ce
trophée en a profité pour annoncer que
jusqu'à une vingtaine de villes
pourraient y participer dans les
prochaines années on a constaté que les
jeunes pour pouvoir prendre confiance en
eux
rien n'est mieux que la promise à sion
théâtrale est donc quelque part si on
peut continuer à croître
allez l'année prochaine dans ces villes
et puis après dans huit villes dans dix
villes et à ce moment là il y aura toute
une série de jeunes qui sont repéreront
à travers la profitation à 4 h
le trophée sera donc encore plus relevé
l'an prochain en attendant les
trappistes ont terminé quatrièmes cette
année
le niveau s'est élevé à la rochefort est
arrivé il ya trois ans des 4e
aujourd'hui
deuxième l'année dernière premier cette
année donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
qualité du jeu d'ailleurs dans toutes
les villes qui s'est élevé et ça c'est
super j'ai adoré franchement si tu es
une aventure à vivre exceptionnels
et voila quoi vous croyez mais pas de
regrets sur la quatrième place du tout
bon pour moi céréales classement parce
que la donner le meilleur de lui même et
trappes ça restera almeria et c'est le
meilleur ambassadeur de cette capitale
de l'impôt qui est donc venu remettre le
prix aux vainqueurs
rochefort déjà finaliste l'an passé mais
moyen rochefort et à bordeaux gagné il
ya des nouvelles
il ya des nouvelles contrées on a
l'impression que petit à petit les gens
les gens rejoignent comme ça le le le
coeur et le coeur ça reste ça reste
déclic théâtre qui en découlent qualité
avec moi tout le long sans se poser de
questions j'ai un juste retour des
choses et puis surtout je pense que
j'aurai toujours envie de faire de
l'impro j'aimerais qu'ils ont envie de
jouer j'aurai toujours envie de j'aurai
toujours envie de partager évidemment je
lâche pas le morceau jeu on a honte ce
lien il a d'effectifs bougera pas et et
tant que je pourrai sans que je pourrais
aller je serai là comme ils ont comme
ils l'ont fait pour moi
je félicite et je fume pour être venu à
acea le grand truc de le grand show de
jamel debbouze
c'était amadou merci tv fil 78 au revoir
merci